[Music]
hey this is Mel strong and this is a
little extra help for people who are
still struggling to understand the
difference between dew point and
relative humidity and how they're
related so I'm gonna use this little
interactive tool from the University of
Wisconsin so I've put a link up on learn
and on my website so you can play with
this too and so over on the right hand
side here cuz we're gonna ignore the
left for now on the right hand side
we've got a thermometer and we've got
dew point and we've got relative
humidity and as I I can make changes in
either the temperature of the dew point
and it will show me how that changes
relative humidity now when we did this
in my previous lecture if you watch my
lecture on relative humidity we
calculated it with mixing ratios now we
could have also done it with dew points
remember both mixing ratio and dew point
tell you how much water is in the air
they're just two different ways of
reporting the same thing but it's the
calculation to get the relative humidity
is much more difficult if you only have
dew point so this doesn't have mixing
ratio in it but it's the same concept so
right now the temperature is a little
bit above sixty degrees the dew point
looks like it's a little below 40 and
our relative humidity is 38 percent okay
so if I raise the temperature so I just
drag this up you notice what's happening
to the relative humidity as that
temperature goes up the relative
humidity goes down so to relate this to
what we've done before with mixing
ratios we said the top of the fraction
was the current mixing ratio that's not
changing because dew point is not
changing remember dew point mixing
really shall have to change together if
I add more water to the air they both go
up if I subtract bar from the air they
both go down the fact that dew point is
not changing tells me that the amount of
water in the air is still a constant but
I mean I increased the temperature just
then
so again to relate that to what we've
seen before I'm dividing by the maximum
possible mixing ratio and the maximum
possible mixing ratio goes up as
temperature goes up dividing by a bigger
number gets me a smaller answer so as I
raise the temperature you saw the
relative humidity decreased so I will
continue the race if the temperature
will make as hot as we can make it
relative humidity goes down the five
percent okay so watch what happens when
I cool it down so I'm going to cool down
the temperature so I cool it down and I
cool it down and notice the relative
humidity is increasing the dew points
not changing because I'm not taking
water from the air okay so I'm going to
tropic further cool it cool it and
notice that the relative humidity
continues to go higher and higher and so
now as I as I'm getting closer and
closer to the dew point the dew points a
little below 40 I'm getting I'm getting
close notice how high my relative
humidity is so I'm gonna drop it even
further
dropped out okay so now relative
humidity is a hundred percent
temperature and dew point are the same
okay
so I'm going to continue to cool it
further so we would be making do at this
point even though the picture shows snow
that's not quite correct because we're
above freezing but we would be making do
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna lower the
temperature so as I lower the
temperature notice what happens to the
dew point the dew point has to go down
with it but the relative humidity stays
at exactly 100% right so I can now we're
below freezing for sure we're making
Frost but I'll keep going down and keep
going down and keep going down and as
long as I keep making it colder and
colder the dew point has to go lower and
lower because I'm taking water out of
the air and putting it onto the ground
at first it was liquid and then it's
frozen but that entire time the relative
humidity was staying at 100% so now
let's say I warm it up so now the dew
point is really low the dew point looks
like it's about negative 10 and as I
warm the temperature up you see the
relative humidity rapidly drop
now this is not completely realistic
because normally what happens if you if
we may do in the more overnight and the
do sitting on the grass then when the
Sun comes up the next day that do
evaporates back into the air at least
most of it does and the dew point would
go back up what this is doing is once we
lowered the dew point it's keeping it
lowered right so that's a not quite what
happens in nature usually so here's
another thing I could do so let me crank
up the temperature to sixty relative
humidity is four percent if I add water
to the air I increase dew point right so
I can crank up the dew point as I
cranked up the dew point relative
humidity is also increasing now in this
case it's increasing because we think
again back to the definition of relative
humidity that we used with with mixing
ratios the top part of that fraction was
the the current mixing ratio how do you
increase the current mixing ratio you
add more water to the air you add more
grams of water to the air increasing dew
point is the same thing if I add water
to the air dew point goes up so we don't
see a process here you have to imagine
there's someone off the screen that's
adding water to the air somehow as I
crank this up so there's some mechanism
that we can't see that as I crank this
up I'm adding do I'm adding water vapor
to the air and the dew point
consequently is going up the temperature
is the same but as I add water relative
humidity goes up with it so go up and up
and up and up and up
and then when I get up to about there I
am 100% relative humidity temperature
and dew point are the same if I it is
physically impossible for me to have dew
point above temperature so the way this
software handles this is if I try to
crank dew point higher it also just
raises the temperature so that you don't
have math that makes no sense but in
reality if I was actually adding water
to the air the temperature does not
magically go up okay that's kind of a
limitation of this of this
software simulation so here two
temperature eighty degrees dew point
eighty degrees relative for me 100% this
would be a pretty miserable place to
live right now if you had this because
you as we talked about with the
evaporation lecture your sweat would not
evaporate so from here if I cool it down
I'm generating a condensation making do
making do making do a relative humidity
again stays of 100% then I can raise the
temperature back up and again the
dewpoint stays there because we have no
mechanism to add or subtract water from
the air so this is a little tool that
you can play with maybe it'll help on
the left hand side there is another
thing where what they're doing is
they've got an indoor thermometers and
so both of these things are outdoor
there's an indoor thermometer and then
indoor relative humidity and you can do
things like you can change the
temperature you can turn the air
conditioner on and off and you can see
what the effect is on the indoor
relative humidity so you can play with
that if you want you can open the door
and let in some outside air and see how
that changes the the point being that
often we have the same air outside as we
have inside right it's usually the same
air and if I have a relative humidity
gauge inside it'll have one reading on
it and I have a relative gate relative
humidity gauge outside it'll have a
different reading on it but the air is
the same why are the readings different
because the temperatures are different
that's why and that's what plane with
this allows you to allows you to mess
with that okay so I don't know if that
helps it up but you can go and play with
this to your heart's content and see if
you can understand the relationship
between dewpoint temperature relative
humidity